in the lobby of the Ramsay Solutions
headquarters Logan and Allison are
joining us hey guys how are you hey Dave
you're doing good
welcome welcome it's an honor to have
you so you're here to do your debt-free
scream we are here we are where do you
guys live I guess in Alabama's but our
north of Birmingham absolutely about an
hour south of here yeah not bad nice
drive up thanks for being here so you're
here how much how much debt of you guys
paid off we paid off 66,000 in debt and
we cash flowed about 35,000 on what
$25,000 wedding a $10,000 master's
degree and then undisclosed amount for
the engagement so when did you get
married I get maybe two and a half years
ago June of 2013 awesome so is that the
time frame for this debt payoff doing
after year no no it was uh I guess it
really right at four years I heard your
name about four years ago and being the
nerd that I am I did a Google search
found Dave Ramsey with your great search
engine optimization you know and yeah
yeah it's pretty good and you know start
listening to your podcast I have an
hour-and-a-half commute for about the
past four years low yeah and so plenty
of time to listen to you you know and
all of the different podcasts and
everything and so we really got on board
I got Allison on board why we were
dating and thank goodness you know this
past June I had an opportunity to go
somewhere else and negotiating that I
was able to stay where I'm at and
actually work from home now so ah it's
so much better your life with a new baby
yeah we have more time to spend with the
family so that's a moyes right excellent
excellent and so what's your average
income through that four years average I
don't really know I guess or what is it
what's the rate we started out about 90
I ended up about 120 cool and what do
you guys do for a living I'm a software
engineer okay I'm a teacher
awesome what grade do you teach first
grade oh that's fine that's a good grade
especially this time of year because
they're completely wire oh you're out of
school now but they're wired for sound
man I mean this is awesome well fun what
kind of debt was the 66,000 that you've
gotten yourself into Logan well as soon
as soon as I got a job I got a car
trading in my other had a $18,000 car
alone $10,000 personal long 32,000 of my
student loans let's see six thousand the
remainder of her car and so that was the
debt awesome Wow okay so two and a half
years ago you get married that's right
and you'd already been working on it for
a year and a half while you were dating
some of that and so Alison at what point
does he come in and start telling you
all this and you're thinking this guy's
not only a software engineer but he's
weird well he told me at the beginning
and it it took me a little bit we
listened to it on the every time we were
in the car and I finally got got on
board with it I'm glad that we did yeah
so you could turn that off and listen to
some music yeah no he still isn't yeah I
remember she she had a she you know has
a big security client she likes to save
and to stay secure and so she owed her
mom I think six hundred dollars and we
were when I was trying to get her on it
she had a thousand dollars sitting
upstairs and her you know night dresser
and so I was like why don't you do that
you know and then she had enough she was
out of debt once I got her on board in
like a month I mean she had been saving
and you know and everything so she was
good to go so when we got married the
majority of it was mine but we worked
together to cash flow the wedding and
all that excellent yeah excellent very
cool so anybody make fun of you guys
while you were doing all this no really
once they make fun we just had a lot of
people who are like you know that's
great for you guys I don't know that it
would work for us but none that you know
just pointing fingers and that's good
that's good an excellent good so what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is when they say wow you paid
off sixty-five there are sixty six
thousand and cash flow to another thirty
five that's a hundred thousand dollars
and four years how'd you do that what do
you tell them the keys are I would say
communication yeah and the weekly and
monthly budgets that took a while to get
used to that yeah she doesn't like to
sit down it took me a while when we
first started doing and wanted to do the
monthly budget meetings or whatever you
know she would get so like that was the
first the first one was the hardest and
then once we got that down I realized
that for you know doing a few times okay
I need to just go through all the
utilities get everything laid out and
then I would bring her in and say okay
what extra do we have this month
and then she you know that way it was
she didn't have to sit there and stare
at the spreadsheet for as long and it
worked out much better for her okay very
cool way to go you guys if you learn to
work together this stage in your
marriage you can do anything
how's it feel to not have any payments
pretty surreal right now yeah that's
great
very cool what was the last debt you
paid off my student loan what was the
one debt that when you paid it off you
went I hate you people I'm so glad
you're going definitely we we found out
back in January we were gonna have our
first child
Eli and you know I've been listening to
you for so long that I'd heard other
people in similar situations and so I
knew as soon as we found out I was like
okay we got to put a pause on the debt
snowball you know so that was kind of
probably one of the most frustrating
things is just having to wait until he
got I was really glad to have that
savings pop very good that was a gift to
your wife though especially with the
security gland that she's got yeah
exactly that's great that was very well
done very wise all right you guys
very well done it's Logan Allison and
Eli and how old is Eli
two months old yes sir all right well
he's pretty young to be doing that free
screen but we'll see how loud he screams
he's cute that's fun all right you guys
you ought to be watching this on the TV
thing with the Rams with the Dave Ramsey
app and then you can see thee lie I love
it all right Logan and Allison an e line
from the against an alabama $66,000 paid
off plus thirty five thousand cash
flowed in four years making 90 to 120
count it down let's hear your debt free
scream three two one we're debt-free
way to go you guys love it love it love
it well done that's how it works right
there you guys would be so rich so fast
and be able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others